it's going to rotate 180 degrees this is
a man himself in much need of a 180
trying to turn things around on a visit
to an oncology unit in kent this is pure
star wars rishi yeah i know but force is
still very much against the pm
political infighting back in westminster
not put to bed and today friction
between these two over money to tackle
record nhs waiting lists today's
expected announcement on that recovery
plan now delayed everybody in number 10
uh
and the treasury uh are working together
in harmony to deal with the the big
problems that the country faces and and
and clearing the covid backlogs getting
so we got large numbers of people coming
forward now
to get
a diagnosis and lots of them didn't get
diagnosed during the pandemic but labour
says delays are not just down to cavity
but conduct at the heart of this
government
you know there's a price to be paid by a
government that is distracted by all
these allegations that are going on and
that price is being paid by the six
million people who are waiting for their
operations
people like mandy and jane both cancer
patients are all too aware of that price
this cancer support center a lifeline
for them there's quite a few times where
i was at the end you know hadn't it been
for georgie in the center
i would come here i could be suicidal
and i know that you know people wanted
me to say it's okay
it's the pandemic and it's fine but it's
not fine
it was far from fine
it made my days
harder
it made them say that i just stopped
getting on
i was just hoping and praying that that
the the the the delays weren't going to
adversely affect it but i was scared
yeah it was definitely
an anxious time
improvements to the lives for millions
on nhs waiting lists depend on decisions
made behind this door the pm changing
his team in the hope it means he can
stay today
the new director of communications with
a not very subtle message swapping in
water for wine but senior conservatives
clear staff changes are simply not
enough he's got to sort this out we're
interested not in the optics in some
impression of a reset we're
looking for a change in the capability
and the character of the government so
that we can have confidence that nothing
as clumsy and mortifying as this
partygate episode could ever happen
again today we had a real life example
not of the political fallout of
partygate but the policy fallout the
much-awaited nhs national recovery plan
was supposed to be published
today but instead it's still caught in
the system amid disagreements between
number 10 the treasury the department of
health the nhs over what targets to set
around cutting waiting lists this is
what happens when the center of
government is not fit for purpose
whitehall insiders say the plan is on
its way but delivering on people's
priorities is hard when your mind's on
your own survival bethrick sky news